morning michael gove of course is with
us here in the studio thank you for
joining us on the program queen's speech
boris johnson says he can't shield
everyone from the cost of living crisis
is what he said so where does he put
that shield
well we try to protect those who are
most vulnerable um we've already taken
steps for example by reducing council
tax for people who are in particular
cancer tax bands who tend to be at the
at the lower end of the income spectrum
but we also keep under review a range of
things that we can do both short term
and long term to help people so for
example in the queen's speech yesterday
there are steps that we're taking to
protect people who are renting both
those in the private rented sector and
those who are also in social homes in
order to ensure that we can have
security for them as well
dominic is on the program later on he's
a single dad he's on universal credit
and he says he's struggling to feed his
family and top up the pre-pay gas meter
will he fall within the uh shield well
we'll do everything that we can there
are individual cases that i know of as a
member of parliament
trying to represent my constituents
effectively with individuals who are in
similar circumstances to dominic who
face very difficult choices and that's
why in government last night the prime
minister convened a meeting of um most
of the cabinet uh everyone who has a
responsibility that bears on cost of
living to make sure that we were all
doing everything that we could to review
every policy disposal every policy lever
at our disposal in order to ensure that
we can help people like dominic and
others so the queen's speech yesterday
had a package of measures many of which
will help but it's also the case that we
don't just rest there we are uh always
in every way looking to see what we can
do to help citizens well let's talk
energy bills as a specific because
that's what dominic is talking about
later on i just saw an interview with
you back from 2016 before brexit and you
said that um after brexit we would cut
vat on fuel bills well after brexit we
could cut v80 on fuel would you said you
would well at the time um i wasn't the
energy secretary at the time i said that
i remember the interview very well that
this was uh one of the things that we
could do outside the european union that
we could not do inside the european
union well what we've chosen to do is to
target the help on the very poorest
cutting vht on fuel bills would mean
that the um help everybody who pays a
fuel bill including the duke of
devonshire um i've got nothing against
the duke but my view is that if you've
got a spare extra pound it shouldn't go
to dukes it should go to people like
dominic why did you highlight it as a
case back in 2016 because it was one of
the freedoms that brexit could bring us
and there are other brexit freedoms
in the queen's speech which will enable
us to both reduce the cost of living
pressures but also to grow the economy
because ultimately for dominic for you
for me the answer to economic pressures
now and in the future is a growing
economy so outside the european union
for example um we can take steps to make
sure that our our farming and our
agriculture and our scientific sector uh
can produce more and can produce more
cheaply but why those bills are in the
queen's beach but why say uh as a result
of uh leaving the european union we
could cut v80 on fuel if you didn't
think it was a good idea um i thought it
was a good idea it is a good idea but
not the priority when you have a cost of
living challenge of the one that we do
at the moment the most important thing
to do is to target help on those people
who are in relative terms poorer
and so they they you know i want to cut
all taxes all the time everywhere but at
the moment we have that are we well we
have to prioritize um i should say that
in the last spring statement in the last
spring statement again
uh rishi showed that when it came to
allocating money his priority would
always be to help the poorest the
changes to universal credit um that uh
he has introduced with therese coffee
the working pension secretary have been
designed to help the poorest and vat on
fuel as i say
all tax cuts great but tax cuts that
help dukes as much as they help others
not necessarily the best at this time
okay so given that you mentioned the
treasury we heard from the prime
minister yesterday saying he will
say more in the days to come on how to
help people with the cost of living and
then almost immediately the treasury is
saying there'll be no emergency budget
and we'll set out the budget timetable
in the usual way so who's right is it is
it going to be an emergency budget or
not um uh they're both right and no
there won't be an emergency budget okay
explain that to me i will um the the key
thing is um it's sometimes the case
would never happen with sky it's
sometimes the case the words from a
prime minister or a minister are
over-interpreted so the prime minister
is right we will be saying more and
doing more in order to help people with
the cost of living a challenge that we
face at the moment but that doesn't
amount to an emergency budget it is part
of the work of government so last night
uh the prime minister convened a group
of ministers we'd all done work on some
of the things that we could do to help
uh those uh those policy initiatives
those policy initiatives will be
announced um uh by individual
departments in due course as they're
worked up but that is part of the uh the
process for a government that is always
and everywhere thinking about how we can
help and how we can provide support both
short term and long term the queen's
speech yesterday it contains legislation
those laws will take a little bit of
time to pass but once they're passed
then they give government the big leave
is necessary to generate economic growth
in the meantime we look to see what we
can do uh more quickly to help but none
of that amounts to an emergency
so therefore both uh the prime minister
and the treasury were right one or two
people who were inclined to
over-interpret uh have now had the
chance to
correct the record or maybe the prime
minister misspoke not that he ever does
that he never does never does that um
leveling up
as your brief of course you've talked
about tackling the astronomical profits
of property developers yeah um what
about the astronomical profits of oil
companies
well we look at all uh economic activity
and we make a judgment about what we can
do in order to help the consumer and to
help them so you're looking at the
astronomical profits of oil companies
no i'm i'm looking specifically at the
uh the property sector and making sure
that uh companies to be fair uh which
have done well out of government funding
in the past um uh play their part in
making sure first of all that they uh
help us to resolve the the building
safety issue the cladding issue that uh
the granville fire so tragically brought
to light and also that we work with them
in order to make sure that more people
have access to high quality beautiful
affordable homes so um you know my my
job in my particular role at the moment
is to
work with uh those building companies
and also to work with local authorities
to get the right homes in the right
places at the right price so you've got
your eye on their astronomical profits
but not on the astronomical profits of
energy companies well as i say the the
position with uh energy uh was outlined
in the uh uh energy strategy that the
prime minister put forward uh uh just a
few weeks ago in which we outlined a
path towards uh energy security for the
long term
and making sure that we can have uh
access to
a dependable supply of lots of different
types of energy that is the right thing
to do
and as has been pointed out uh if you
have the wrong astronomical profits of
the oil industry well if you have the
wrong sort of tax
applied
at the wrong time and in the wrong way
you can actually lead to companies not
investing for the long term epp said
they said nonsense we'll continue on
with our investment whether there's a
windfall tax or not well you'll find
many other people not just in the oil
and gas sector but many other people who
are observing the the picture when it
comes to energy overall who would make
the point very eloquently that if you
have a tax that is introduced uh uh as i
say at the wrong time and in the wrong
way that will deter the investment we
need in order to ensure that we have oil
and gas in the north sea okay for the
long term so i was in aberdeen my
hometown recently one of the things that
uh people said to me there is
uh if we're going to have a transition
towards net zero yeah oil and gas has to
be part of that yeah we need investment
we won't get that investment if we have
the wrong sort of tax applied now okay
we've uh i'd love to press you on that
more but we've not got time because i
want to talk to you about the northern
ireland protocol of course what's the
plan
well we want to make sure that we have a
situation in northern ireland where
people can have access to the goods from
the rest of the united kingdom uh that
they have every right to enjoy how are
you gonna do it uh well negotiation
we're gonna make sure that uh we're not
just gonna rip up the deal no we're
going to talk to the eu but nothing is
off the table um one of the things that
the brexit process
well
nothing is off the table
three things from the brexit negotiation
one
uh boris
in the past has proved himself to be an
expert negotiator and has secured what
he's needed when he's needed it secondly
part of that is being prepared to say
look if i don't get what i want in this
negotiation i am prepared to walk away
and to use alternative methods and three
and three yeah he did do a deal in the
end and then three
always always always always always
always make sure that you have some
cards you keep close to your chest so
that you don't reveal your hand entirely
to the other so this is what schultz
says he says we have found a good way
for northern ireland and no one should
unilaterally i.e the uk override the
arrangement which we have agreed
together yes but one of the whole points
about the protocol and i know because i
was involved in making sure that the
protocol would work is that there's a
committee that's been set up to monitor
how it operates the whole reason we have
that committee is that the the protocol
as it was agreed contained lots of areas
with required further work that's why
we've got negotiations if that further
work in negotiations uh can't yield the
results that we need then nothing is off
the table okay um the irish t-shirt says
he's worried about the peace process
should he rip up the deal and the deputy
leader has also been talking about that
and he says we can't have any unilateral
action from the uk this is an
international agreement they have to
honor their obligation we do have
obligations and we have them under the
good friday agreement the belfast good
friday agreement and what we want to do
is to make sure that in northern ireland
the executive the the government of
northern ireland uh comes together that
means you need to get people from both
sinn fein and the dup together at the
moment the situation with the protocol
is a barrier to getting the executive
back together a
barrier to fulfilling the agreement it's
not the it's not the european union's
fault that the uk has signed a bad deal
as far as you're concerned uh well it's
going to lead to trade wars which means
a further increase in the cost of living
no um well that's what the eu's saying
well as we've seen before in uh
negotiations uh there are some actors on
one side of the negotiation one side of
the discussion who will say certain
things and that's fine i'm not going to
criticize them but i think the important
thing is to recognize that in boris and
in list trust we have two tough
negotiators boris and liz together
secured not just our deal on exit from
the eu but a number of free trade
agreements that people said that we
couldn't sign in that time so i you know
full respect to olive schultz and uh leo
veradka but boris and liz they are the
negotiating duo here we go
simon hall conservative chair of the
northern ireland select committee he
says no honorable country should act
unilaterally within an agreement
well uh simon uh i understand uh uh
knows a great deal about the protocol
because he's the chairman of the
northern ireland select committee as as
you say and he will know as i've said
that what we are seeking to do is to
negotiate and uh liz uh the foreign
secretary is seeing maharashtrikovich
the eu vice president uh tomorrow will
be keeping up at home with all these
names yes tomorrow that's diplomacy um
in order to make sure that um
we can take steps uh to resolve this
issue right so we are we are talking uh
that is what um
you know that's what foreign when will
we see whether you're either going to
rip up this agreement or not next week
this week months time uh there isn't any
23. there isn't anything that's going to
be ripped up what we are doing is making
sure that we safeguard the position of
people um who are in northern ireland
within the united kingdom it is our
responsibility as the government of the
whole united kingdom to make sure that
people there have uh uh
are fully citizens of this country and
that the peace process is protected in
order to protect the peace process we
need to make sure that we get that
executive back up and running just
before i let you go um
how comfortable do you feel honestly
about the most law-breaking uh street in
london being where the prime minister
lives
i'm not sure what you mean 50 fixed
penalty notices so far more to come
probably for the prime minister as well
does that
sit happily with you
uh
this is a big issue it relates of course
to what went on in downing street and
indeed um more broadly that's the answer
it has to be said well i think that uh
i've been asked about this many times
and what i've i hope always said is for
anyone who um as so many people did
suffered during the pandemic it will be
difficult um to contemplate that uh laws
and rules were broken
i'm explaining exactly how i feel
because the question was a short and
pithy one
but it requires unpacking because there
is so much behind it but ultimately i
think that you have to judge these
things in the round um and uh my view is
uh that the prime minister and the
people who worked in number 10 downing
street um uh
uh contributed to getting the big
questions right in the pandemic um and
as recent figures show
the united kingdom even though the
government was roundly criticized the
united kingdom and it's not a race but
the united kingdom
uh did a better job collectively of
handling the covert uh pandemic than
many other countries and that is down to
the prime minister's leadership
we're out of time it's good to see you
thank you very much thank you thank you